foreign
so in my household my husband is not a
consumer but he's a huge hoarder and um
he has a hard time letting things go
whereas I'm the consumer but I'm willing
to let things go very easily and I also
do all the organizing in our home and so
going back to what you said earlier TK
about you don't want to change them you
want them to learn for themselves
but I still get resentful when I'm the
one that's moving that box you know and
so I guess I just want to know if you
guys could give me some encouragement
too
either change how I feel or change him
um
yeah but that's it
because I'm tired of being mad at him
somebody yelled True Crime
crime
like we're gonna see Pua on
an upcoming serial podcast
coming soon the hoarder
four-part series on Netflix
[Laughter]
so there are two things here there's one
the my husband is a hoarder part and the
kind of judgment that goes along with
that and then there is the two
his hoarding might be fine for him but
it seems like the responsibility to
manage it move it around and so on falls
on me and both of those are very
important so the first part I think one
of the hardest things to do in life is
to articulate beliefs that we ourselves
do not share and
I think it's very important to not be
too confident about your ability to
Define what someone else believes right
you you want to be able to Define
another person's beliefs in a way that
an actual believer of that would listen
to and say yeah that's about right so if
I'm a socialist and I'm defining
capitalists if I'm a capitalist and I'm
defining socialists can I articulate it
in such a way that someone who actually
believes this thing I don't believe
would listen to it and say yeah hey you
explain me pretty well if you practice
this in most cases you will find that no
matter how good you are at that people
who actually believe it will be like
kinda right like like that's mostly
right but I would add this bit of nuance
why is that an important concept it's
important because it's easy to take our
labels like hoarder which has a very
personal meaning for us and then impose
that on someone else who could be doing
exactly what they want to do and could
be filling a lot of Joy with it and say
well you're a hoarder too because if I
were you and I did what you did I would
be so anxious about all the clutter in
my life Josh and I talk about this all
the time right clutter for me may not be
clutter for him and vice versa and so
the first step I would take
is aiming to connect with him rather
than aiming to correct him and I would
get curious about his clutter not as
some game of manipulation not as some
pretentious sort of thing but you're
never going to be able to help him nor
are you ever going to be able to inspire
him if you are not understanding of the
underlying fundamental reasons for why
he wants to hang on those hang on to
those things it could be possible that
if he opens up and tells you the story
behind these things you might even say
oh
you know what you should keep that stuff
let's just find a better way to deal
with the space that it takes up or you
might find that when he begins to tell
his story about why these things are
there he might even begin to see for
himself where there's room to change
things around Ryan shared on a recent
episode this really powerful practice I
hadn't thought about before where he
says him and Mariah will sometimes get
together and they'll say and they'll ask
each other what are the things you want
to work on in your life right and it's
very easy to be like here's what I think
you need to work on
but that produces a lot of defensiveness
and a whole lot of other baggage but
when you ask the other person you might
find that that thing about them that's
been irritating you is also irritating
them too and the thing they need the
most is not for someone else to give
them information that they already know
but for someone else to know that what
they really need is support because
they're struggling to deal with the
things that are irritating you too and I
think it's very important to start with
curiosity and connection before we fool
around with any efforts to try to get
people to behave differently I believe
it was John Maxwell who said people
don't care how much you know until they
know how much you care you gotta connect
first the meeting is on the calendar
that my wife and I have uh every month
we started doing this a few months ago
it's called a life dinner and it really
is like a sitting down and like hashing
out
um yeah where we're going in life what
we want to do what are our directions
that we're trying to head in and it's a
real it's a great mechanism of support
and it never turns into
here's what I think you should do it and
that's really important that that it
doesn't turn into that I think that's a
great idea like to ask your husband to
have a life dinner once a month or maybe
it's once a quarter whatever works for
you and him but you know ultimately when
it comes to the issue right now today
um you obviously can't change your
husband but you can change your
relationship with that box
so you are choosing to move that box
and the question is
is he worth it like when you move that
is it worth moving that box
every single day to be with him if
Mariah was a hoarder and I had to move
boxes every day
I think I'd move those boxes every day I
love that woman
can I ask you a question
what bothers you about his stuff I guess
it's because I'm on this journey to have
less stuff I have four kids I'm trying
to simplify my life
and he the stuff that he has are from
his childhood that he doesn't look at he
doesn't
want to look at because he doesn't have
time sure and
I have to make space
or I it's the Clutter that's stressful
to me like not that I see it it's
stressful and that's why I keep moving
it why do you want to simplify your life
because
it's not inherently good
just like your your husband isn't
inherently wrong for having things
and I hear a lot of I hear a lot of
upset and discontent and I'm really
sorry because I can I could feel it in
you and I felt that same thing there's a
tension between you and this person you
love and if things were just a little
bit different
then maybe things would be fine
but really this is all just Furniture
we're moving around Furniture right now
literally and figuratively
um
let me change the yeah if you paint a um
a house that is
rotting with termites
makes the house look a little bit better
but it doesn't actually get to the root
of what's going on here yeah and so I'd
like to try to figure out
what's really going on behind all of
this
what's going on with his attachment his
unwillingness to let go of anything that
by the way it's only clutter because it
doesn't add value to his life now he
could be here is he here right now no
he's no of course not
he wanted to come so we could say
whatever we want about it yes okay let
me record it for him
I would not say anything I wouldn't say
to his face but here's what I would um
here's what I would say to him if he
were here is why why are you holding on
to these things but no I wouldn't do so
I hear the Judgment in your voice and I
totally get it but remember that
judgment is just a mirror that reflects
the insecurities of the judge and so
when I judge my wife or my daughter or
my friends for something that they are
doing
or something that they have done what
I'm really saying is that doesn't align
with something that I want right
showing my own expectations my own
preferences my own opinions my own
beliefs
about that it doesn't make them true and
it doesn't make me right and him wrong
or vice versa right and so
you don't have to answer this question
right now but I'd really like you to
figure out why
are you simplifying
what's on the other side of that what
are you actually making room for yeah a
less cluttered house is nice but a less
cluttered house isn't going to repair
your relationship did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free